[Music]
uh february 25th and 26th i'll be in
kansas city missouri at the comedy club
of kansas city march 10th through the
12th i'll be in springfield missouri at
the blue room comedy club and then uh
salt lake city april 8th and april 9th
i'll be at wiseguys comedy club tickets
at chapellelacey.com
enjoy this episode with my friend
david ruthless lucas yeah you probably
was already tired i was man that was
like the [ __ ]
that was like the tail end of the
[ __ ] yeah bro uh how long did it take
to finish that whole thing we're going
right
uh how how long did it take or how long
is it supposed to take how long it's
supposed to
i think it's supposed to take like nine
miles
9.6 i mean i think like the the beast
time is like two hours yeah right casey
yeah because it ain't just nine miles of
running that's nine miles of getting
electrocuted that's not yeah nine miles
to get that i'll be funny that was just
every
consistent of every [ __ ] thing that
[ __ ] hurt hurt or not i actually didn't
get shocked i was the only one
i was the only one that get to get shot
he got shocked he got a bruise on his
elbow
hurt like a [ __ ] what made
[ __ ] want to do that like what is
because they said
that's what i understand you just got to
do it yeah it's like bro you don't get
no contract no you don't get a contract
you know you don't get a deal
no money no no money no sponsors i get
it it's people who like to do that like
uh david goggins who run them extreme
marathons yeah people just a lot of
times i think it's just for [ __ ]
people's like mental and to push your
body to them yeah yeah yeah yeah push it
to the limit i push your nerves i wonder
how navy seal would do on that they
probably killed it there's another
[ __ ] heartbeat
yeah could they be doing something
i was talking to one of rogan's
bodyguards who was a seal bro he was
telling me about hell week bro he said
don't next get like three hours of sleep
and you don't know what three hours of
sleep a day and you don't know you don't
know and you don't know when the sleep
gonna be
listen i was sitting here crying and
bitching about that tough mudder
and no [ __ ] get three hours for
a week right and he was like sometimes
they went to bed wet
but but what yeah like because he was
like because he was because you're like
out in the [ __ ] right and he was like
they'll be sleep
and for the [ __ ] the drill starts to
be like all right buddy float and they
all got to go jump in the water
and [ __ ] hold each other like
arms together and [ __ ] float and then
rolling sand they'd be like all right
hit the bunks that [ __ ] are you serious
bro i would have been went home
[Laughter]
but you did football and [ __ ] yeah but
that's not football man you're right
you're right you're right you're right
yeah that's right i've never done
football so i don't know i mean it looks
like y'all go hard in the paint
but the thing right the thing about
the thing about me i was a lineman so
you you only got to be in shape for 15
seconds at a time you know what i'm
saying like is that it that a play is
like 10 to 15 seconds oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah okay okay you don't got to be in
though you don't have a crazy ass [ __ ]
to where you need to run 9-10 miles
lyman uh
o-line or d-line d-line i know what i'm
doing
i don't know what the hell i'm talking
about so yeah bro like you know what i'm
saying like football players
you know like especially linemen that we
have quick bursts of speed and energy
but like if we had to [ __ ] do some
basketball type [ __ ] it'll be hard yeah
because yeah a lot of cardio with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's why big dudes
can play football yeah yeah because you
only got to be in shape you know what
i'm saying for 15 20 seconds 15 20
seconds at a time that's easy now that i
didn't think about it that's pretty easy
yeah it's easier than tough mudder [ __ ]
like i tell you that the guy he never
did nothing there
would you
no
you all say yeah see you like that's
what that's why i [ __ ] with you you know
when you all sat on the i'm good like
you you okay to say it too you're like
good yeah i'm good i don't give a [ __ ]
i mean the hardest thing i probably did
in football bro
was probably like stadium stairs with
another [ __ ] on my back
yeah that was hard
meanwhile they ain't got nothing to do
with football
football they got nothing to [ __ ] do
not a [ __ ] thing that's the bad part
tough mudder ain't got nothing to do
with anything
but yeah like i don't
i mean there is a point
like
so like you do kind of got to like be in
some type of shape because like
even though you're only going for 10 to
15 seconds you're taking hits from other
two and 300 pounds yeah [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] all that i missed that [ __ ] bro you
do
wait because wait uh
you you stopped at what age 19
19 and that's when you started doing
comedy well i started comedy younger
than that like
i i was dabbling with you one of them
you one of them eddie murphy types yeah
started at 15 years old not like 17
maybe i dabbled into that 17 after the
obama show
at the oh oh really dude i remember that
show yeah that show was i loved that
[ __ ] show i think i got a clip on my
wait you were on it mm-hmm wait you're
on your mama yeah no
oh by the way we have david lucas
my guest today is david are we already
podcasting yeah we're podcasting oh you
cool with that
y'all [ __ ] tricky david david ruthless
lucas is what i [ __ ] call you come on
man come on man yeah i'm saying i see
you do the damn thing bro first of all
how the [ __ ] you know how to sing
uh
all fat [ __ ] concerned what
[Laughter]
is that true
show me a fat boy who can't say
oh eric griffin
yeah he's not fat
i mean he chunky he chunky we're not fat
yeah but he he got like reuben stuttered
yeah
let's listen all the fat dude barry
white
he was fat he could sing are you only
talking about fat black dudes think
about yeah think about church
the best singers was fat black man
what did you type in casey
with that body bro he probably can blow
he can belt yeah he can be wait you sang
in church yeah that's what i said you
did yeah
i bet they were strict as [ __ ] too
uh yeah ain't never give a [ __ ] you
didn't oh you didn't give a [ __ ] i never
cared about consequences and i think
that's why i lied
you know what you don't yeah you [ __ ]
don't because you just be saying [ __ ]
sometimes and i'm like david hey hey hey
hey
but i mean like i've always been like
that since i was a kid my youngest
daughter but you're not malicious you're
not like trying to like
ruin people or like
physically hurt people like you just say
[ __ ] yeah you ain't trying to like
[ __ ] just say what i want but also
you don't you don't start anything
it's only if it comes your way exactly
that's exactly how it works i'm not just
a [ __ ] starter you know no you don't you
don't start yeah i've never seen you
start [ __ ] not at all man as soon as
something one person goes
it's a [ __ ] rap man listen you better
come with it
my favorite is when the uh when we were
in denver
and that dude what did he try what did
he call you i thought he was calling me
fat ass but he said he was talking to
another fat ass he said he wasn't yeah
he said he was talking to his friend but
i was like all right i'm standing up for
all the fat asses oh damn yeah yo and
you lit him the [ __ ] dummy
[Laughter]
one of my favorite moments of going on
the road with you was that [ __ ]
denver was a struggle bro it was a
struggle but even i wouldn't say for big
people but even though little cow was
struggling bad oh yeah everybody's
struggling breathing out there that
elevation thinking about doing a tough
mudder out there [ __ ] never
you [ __ ] it was hard it was hard
enough to walk i know we couldn't even
walk anywhere we couldn't do [ __ ] bro we
have the most fun on the road though
yeah we do like everyone thinks we all
be out partying this [ __ ] we just be
talking we'll be doing regular [ __ ] the
most regular we'll be in our underwear
talking [ __ ] about youtube videos they
they start off because i still be asleep
they start out to go get coffee
then after they get their coffee we find
something you just be [ __ ] sleeping i
mean cuz i be up to like three or four
in the morning watching watching [ __ ]
the most random youtube videos in the
[ __ ] world what was that jay said he
caught me watching one time it's almost
like infomercial and i'm like what the
[ __ ] is and it's all loud it's called
the infographic show what is that they
just have like random videos about
everything bro like
they really do like if you want to know
like how neon likes romaine they'll have
a
light i mean they have a video
what is it called the infographic show
[ __ ] is infographic there there
but they release a video like every day
how many subscribers they got
11 million 11 million and it's literally
videos on [ __ ] anything
bro they got a video that's on there it
says trapped underwater for three days
oh that's about that african man bro
that's actually pretty interesting he
was trapped on the water yeah how he
survived uh in a pocket of air
it's pretty interesting and he had to
stay like in a uh
a decompression it was an african dude
yeah it was an african dude
was he a chef
but he i don't remember i think he was
like taking a [ __ ]
when the boat went down and that's what
saved his life because he was like
locked in a bathroom
oh yeah but they came to check the boat
the first day and they didn't think
anybody could survive because it was
under there and then they came back like
the third day i guess to like tag bodies
or whatever
and they [ __ ] found his black ass
that's it yeah bro
damn yeah well i'm i'm i'm glad you uh
showed about that yeah that's you should
watch it
now i think i i think i'm uh
partaking this that's actually a very
good i actually [ __ ] highly doubt i
will ever bro that's actually a very
good one and then they got one
about uh
they got so many bro but like
and it's just a random [ __ ] person
explaining all this [ __ ] yes a random
white guy's voice
they don't even tell you who the white
guy is no probably steve or something
probably steve that sounds about right
steve steve sound like a [ __ ]
dude that would do that
yeah they got the most random videos but
like they got a video about a guy who
was raising a tiger in an apartment in
new york
and they caught him because people were
complaining about the odor
and then like when when the police was
the older just the stock ass tiger
and then when the police like raided his
apartment he had like a tiger a bear
like some alligators in an apartment
yeah
snake he's just crazy bro
people crazy that's why you be talking
so much [ __ ] why is that because you
know so much [ __ ] yeah i mean you got to
kind of know a lot you kind of got to
know a lot
and [ __ ] yeah you got to know a lot bro
you you started your new show flat line
with this online game game how you feel
about it man it's dope bro it's dope bro
isn't that that's such a dope concept
ain't no more roasting on instagram live
y'all want to get roasted you got to
come to youtube i know yeah because uh i
remember yeah
like just seeing you on the road do that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] insane like you just
[ __ ]
get on there and at first i was like
what's he doing i was like who's he mad
at like i thought it was i thought it
was someone that like cause you told me
there's times where like you went live
with people or something and you're like
like people that talk [ __ ]
you know what i mean people that have
just rolled up and like some ignorant
[ __ ] before no yeah people that'll just
roll up and just like
say [ __ ] like oh you [ __ ] dummy yeah
why do you follow me yeah it's like yeah
i would never that is that i will never
understand why people follow things they
don't like
it's probably you you got to be the
dumbest i think
i think they're like
like overly obsessed with us because you
know like uh like and or here's how i
feel in order to hate something you
gotta love it
so you you because like how can you hate
something if you don't love it you don't
even know it so you've
you're watching every one of my videos
you know everything about me you got a
shitty ass life and you're like this man
out here doing it yeah and you're like
man [ __ ] this dude
i don't like you i don't like the way
you look you really love me dog yeah
but you don't reply in comments
um you used to huh i used to read every
comment and now like i'll get a few and
with the new structure of instagram i
don't like it what is it like bro
they'll show like
i don't it's weird bro how the news
struck oh like people can't talk [ __ ] to
you they can but like how they show like
comments and follows and stuff now is
weird oh oh yeah
like the the actual then when you get
the notification yeah but um like if i'm
just on instagram and i see it
you know what i'm saying i'll comment
without comment you'll say if i know if
i know you i can't [ __ ] do it if i
know the person if you know the person
if you don't know the person you're not
going to reply unless they just say
something so like out there where i need
to make a point make a [ __ ] point i
can't do it like when when i see people
like repose
like or post um
like a laughing emoji or dope or
congrats i'll at least like like it to
acknowledge it yeah yeah that's that's
fine like i can handle that [ __ ] yeah
yeah you know like if people are being
nice like i could handle that yeah but
if people are just being [ __ ] i'm
like
[ __ ] you i just can't find it in my
heart to [ __ ] reply to that [ __ ] so
usually i just welcome mark welcome to
my block party mark on the other hand
mark got time professional
what they call them people professional
professional troll yeah
well he does
is it troll or is it like because he's
not really or a responder to troll let's
say that he'll yeah he'll respond to a
troll in a [ __ ] heart he's yeah he's
like
wild how much he does not give her
because like you're you're on site
you know what i mean like yours is
different yours is on site right you say
some [ __ ] to people like right yeah
right to their [ __ ] face i'd be
seeing his post bro and then i'll go
read his comments could it be so funny
because he just be responding to
everybody everybody he responds that's
probably why his algorithm is dope
because his interaction oh his are his
engagement or whatever
yeah because he just [ __ ] and he puts
that energy out he put like 200 stories
on his i know god damn but he's really
good at it because like it is funny
watching people talk like talk [ __ ] to
you right that literally don't know you
and like
don't nobody talk and then when you
reply back
what i've noticed is like they're always
like oh triggered
don't nobody talk [ __ ] unless they got a
private page
i see some people with
there's some people that have come at me
okay they might have a personal pay i
mean they might have an open page but
it's like full of memes or or oh yeah
it's always like means something it's
never down it might be one picture of
them oh it's like one picture of them
and it's foggy as hell
yeah and it's just like yeah it's like
oh okay i catch you this is a burner
account
you got a burner account don't you yeah
i got a fence why does everybody [ __ ]
have a burner so i'm gonna talk [ __ ]
for real yeah
why it's fun he got a burner you should
he got a casey got a burner yeah you
don't have a runner casey okay casey is
kind of quiet i ain't talking [ __ ] from
my page get that [ __ ] disabled
oh
i get it
nah
you don't want your page disabled right
so you just create the burner yeah so
you'll be like yo you dumb [ __ ]
oh
ruthless lucas yeah come
[Music]
on i get it jumping dms you know i get
it dm diving
i know i still can't do that that's a
lot of energy yeah
i don't know i just don't think i care
that much instagram
i can't let myself care that much
instagram the best dating app why that's
how you be what finding uh
what are you
that's how i found my wife
oh you got a wife nah but i mean you
know
they will be
hold up i don't know what to say in this
portion of this part no that's all good
bro okay yeah yeah well yeah we'll talk
about it yeah we got a girl about it oh
it was david
i don't know your life like that i know
your life but i don't know it like that
nah i don't know how old you are about
what's
what's good in your life what's
understood don't have to be sad
that's what my granny's always saying
any [ __ ] ways
yo so anyways let's jump into some
[ __ ] music [ __ ]
um you pretty much you do listen
everything
you [ __ ] with country [ __ ] with
alternative obviously [ __ ] with hip hop
yeah uh and even tibetan monk chants
i like that [ __ ] really
like how halo sounds oh
you hear that
i told you this [ __ ] can see
now we'll get him to sing uh johim in a
second uh
wait really
i don't think i've ever touched that
world
actually is it more like meditation
music yeah
like yeah but you don't meditate i do i
meditate every morning oh you do yeah oh
you you get at it yeah
huh
yeah i never knew that about it i mean
that's how i stay balanced you know what
i'm saying yeah bro like you know like
like how they say like praying is
putting
your
your problems or what you need solutions
to into the universe or god whatever
superior being you believe in and then
meditating is actually taking the time
to listen to it
you know what you know what i think that
it actually makes sense that you do it
because if there's one thing i've
noticed
obviously we know you roast and you
you're ready to like
you know whenever people come at you
you're always ready for it right it
makes it like
the meditation probably helps you yeah
you got to be balanced bro be really
good at that i had to deal with some i
had to deal with a chick the other night
at a show a heckler oh good i know it's
rare for me did you flip onto the table
no i didn't flip it down and put my
table
but i was so i was doing a show i was
doing one of those like uh secret shows
or whatever what's the don't tells oh
they don't tell you
and
you know i had that joke about wine
drinkers right mm-hmm
and
she goes uh-uh
i was like
i was like what's up like she's like
you're not just gonna sit up here and
talk [ __ ] about wine drinkers i thought
she was joking i was like this is an odd
thing to who defends wine yeah bruh i
thought i thought it was so weird like
like i was like oh i was like wait you
serious that you know and then i was
like you know at first it was a joke but
actually i do [ __ ] hate wine drinkers
right i said that to her and then
because because i was like oh she
probably just bantering back right no
she was dead [ __ ] serious she goes
she goes you're not going to sit here
and talk about wine drinkers i paid to
see you i said you didn't pay to see me
i was like you didn't know the lineup
it's a secret show so you didn't even
you didn't even know i was here you
don't even know who i am or whatever she
goes she goes it don't matter i know the
owner i know the owner of this place and
then i was like
how are you gonna be black and act like
a karen karen like a mouth bruh
it was like insane drunk ass
it wouldn't wouldn't stop and then was
pacing back and forth outside waiting to
talk to me was she good looking
uh
hell no no no obviously not if i had to
take that one pretty girls don't heckle
no
never seen she was she was aggressive
yeah she was like she goes i'll talk to
you after the show i was like
it's always you ugly [ __ ] that are
so [ __ ] irritated at the [ __ ] we say
a pretty girl
a pretty girl has never been irritated
anything that comes out of my mouth
because they're pretty
but you hoes who can't get the men that
you want
come to shows with a [ __ ] chip on
your shoulder and then when something
hits home
you feel like it's a personal attack
against your character
uh
does the rest of the staff agree with
that
on that
y'all agree y'all agree with me right
you really do feel that you feel that
i've never had a pretty heckler
yeah it's usually always someone that's
right they're ugly man you're right ugly
life ain't [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
they they almost couldn't make the show
because nobody didn't want to watch
their kids nobody and nobody wanted to
go with them they never got a date
rarely well that one time
when we were in uh what was that spokane
or tacoma
and that that irish chick heckle and she
was with her boyfriend oh that was
tacoma
but he's a bitch-ass [ __ ] why
why you say that you can't control your
woman
my woman ain't going to do that if i'm
out bro i mean that's that's fair that's
fair i mean i i that's fair i saw my
girl with my grandma ass like yeah and
and you did i might get triggered and do
that you want to embarrass me while we
out in public
your arm is going to be sore on that car
ride home because i'm going yank the
[ __ ] out of your ass
david that [ __ ] tried to get on stage
with me and she got a boyfriend at the
table she's straight up trying to get on
[ __ ] stage she's straight up bro
she's straight up trying to get on stage
how to put my girl a headlock like no
lie they don't leave no more did you
post that video yeah
go to david's instagram
look at him
[Music]
what's up boom
huh
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
the audacity she had it was crazy to get
on that [ __ ] stage and her dude was
there she she messaged me actually she
did she's trying to holler no she just
apologized and she was like when you
come back
like i have dinner and a bottle of wine
for you
she's trying to holla because her man
ain't [ __ ]
i mean he
her man can't be [ __ ] he can't be [ __ ]
yeah you ain't me tomorrow dinner
that's fair dinner in a bottle of wine
yeah what the [ __ ] what yeah
and that that and that's my [ __ ]
thing about you you don't instigate
anything no but some people just [ __ ]
try it man i
i think it's my style of comedy too like
it's it's
like i'm very controversial on stage
like i say a lot of [ __ ] that people
think and you know
you say what
most people are [ __ ] thinking yeah i
don't i don't got no night no david
letterman set or whoever conan said
whoever the [ __ ] conan whatever
whoever doing them
whoever doing a little five minute late
night casey if you don't put up
conan in the barbarian
when he sets that bar yeah whoever
he said conan
yeah there you go there you go right
there see i don't got no uh no tv set
well yeah that's what i like about you
because like if i had to if i had to
compare your style of comedy
to like
uh like if we took it to music terms
right and i had to compare your style
of just brutally honest i would compare
it to like an ice cube
like nwa
like that stuff where they're like a
tupac like right where they just said
what most people
are pretty much [ __ ] thinking and
america needs that now more than ever
bro oh big time
bro you know like do you think do you
think that's fair
to compare your style to that yeah
that's cool this
why not yeah yeah okay yeah no again
because
i mean
you know when i think of ice cube he's
one of my he's one of my [ __ ]
all-time favorites yeah he dope he just
[ __ ]
he'll tell her like it is and he
literally does not give a [ __ ] like
there's there's no like uh
not not it's not the uh not remorse but
um
like he said what he said and that's it
right yeah he's not scared of
consequences either no yeah he's not
scared of the consequences okay like
when he was coming up with the platinum
plan for for black people oh yeah yeah
and they people went hard on him uh yeah
because he's because he was going to sit
down with uh black people the republican
side side or whatever black people as a
whole we lost dog
[Laughter]
y'all so
that man trying to get us tangibles and
y'all talking about he's sitting with
trump i know what's yeah that was the
weirdest [ __ ] thing i was like man he
what did he do wrong
like ice cube said he said uh
what he said he said black people then
get shot by the police but we don't have
i forgot the exact words he used but he
was basically talking about like the
wealth gap and what he was trying to
propose was to get black people
tangible actual
funds lane resources resources and he
was like so at least when police shoot
black people it'll cost them something
but they're like nah you hit trump
they're like are you listening to what
yeah yeah they that's so [ __ ] crazy
2020 bro
2019 was just a weird time people were
so bored they would just want to cancel
people for any little thing bro
well 2020 when the pandemic started they
just want to cancel people for
any longer
man it was like y'all so y'all didn't go
back to work
every week y'all canceling somebody yeah
people can't even speak they mind it is
weird man like it's like um
yeah and that's what i like appreciate
about you is that you you truly
do speak your mind it's on and off off
the stage
and
and it's like that that's become like a
like almost like a taboo thing right
in our society right and when you think
about art itself
you know
i love ice cube because of his honesty
bro andy warhol would be canceled if he
was living in this year yeah
and it's just like like a lot of it's
just like it's it's
i don't know like
people just take certain things as if
someone's just being malicious
you know to a crazy extent exactly bro
they act like
they be acting like our jokes are going
they're talking about
like
raping people that nobody's even saying
anything like that we're just speaking
our mind and it it was like the whole
dave chappelle
thing bro just
and then it's like you know that
community that he was talking about it's
like y'all doing this and it's gonna be
like the boy who cried wolf so when it's
really actually something
that's oppressing y'all or that could
potentially be harmful to y'all nobody's
going to want to hear it because you
made such an uproar about what he had to
say yeah yeah and a lot of times i think
the people the things that people go at
isn't the problem
you know that's like i don't think that
person is the problem right i mean we
were talking a little bit about it
yesterday like the way um
um
like when neil young like did this
took his music off spotify and joni
mitchell yeah uh also i think uh yeah
but neil young old and he sold like half
his catalog last year for 150 million
so like i mean does he really care yeah
does he really care i don't know how
much but also at the same time it is
like a weird
like
i don't think rogue is the person people
need to be mad at right because i got a
platform y'all mad at somebody with a
platform yeah you bet it's someone and
it's a
like
the most honest platform you could
probably get and when have we not been
able to question science
that's what science is all about yeah so
it's like
yeah and it's like yeah it's like i mean
people like people can't have
conversations
people can't just like talk and that
that's where we get [ __ ] up it's like
people don't want to talk because it's
like no you're you're wrong and it's
like [ __ ] you're wrong
subjective dog you know what i mean like
that's like that's the [ __ ] yeah
struggle we go through on a regular
[ __ ] basis i'm not trying to make you
believe what i believe and i ain't gonna
believe what you believe
just let it be bro you got your opinion
i got mine yeah and it's it's like let
why can't i just have that right you
know what i mean why can't i just have
that that's why that's why i don't speak
out much about a lot of things because
i'm like you know what i'm gonna
strictly
keep this [ __ ] to myself right right i
don't like talking to people about
[ __ ] politics yeah religion yeah i
don't like talking to people certain
people i don't like talking to people
about vaccine [ __ ] yeah you know like
i'm just like i don't want to have the
conversation
at all whichever way you [ __ ] think
even if you do think to a similar
standpoint of what i do right i still
don't want to [ __ ] talk to you about
it because it's like can i just have
like can i have these things to my
[ __ ] self like why do i have to make
it about other [ __ ] people right you
know what i mean like and it's it's and
that's how i feel when i'm on stage like
that lady got offended about wandering
[ __ ] ain't about you
saying about you i called her a [ __ ]
listen i didn't mean
oh he meant it to to say
well if he don't mean it i mean i meant
like
like that was a
it was a naughty move on her part is
when i said that's what i meant when i
said
[ __ ]
he was saying are you going to edit that
part out cause he was saying he was
saying
he was saying [ __ ] as in female dog and
you know they say a dog is man's best
friend so he was basically saying she's
not my best friend
that lady was not my best friend that
night that's yo bestie
i mean but like
needless to say yeah like like it's yeah
like that's why i love the world of
standup because literally it's me on
stage by myself yeah and like this is
the moment i get to have to [ __ ] talk
about the things that have to do with
me and my personal thoughts or whatever
bro and it's like i'm telling it in a
goofy [ __ ] way
yeah in a hundred years we're gonna be
extinct bro and that's fine
[ __ ] it
you know that's that's why that's why i
don't get too stressed out about [ __ ]
cause i'm like listen i got [ __ ] one
life well i'm talking about stand-up
comics
oh you think we'll be extinct yeah it'll
be a whole bunch of improv [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah right
it's because it's like bro the like
when you see
that like
because like right along the time when
we were kids maybe middle school for us
you started getting this participation
trophy [ __ ] yeah you know what i'm
saying and that's
what started this
did you assume how old are you 32 32 so
it's like so i think it started around
your time because when i was when i was
a kid when you sucked
they let it be known okay yeah but i
remember it was like
i remember i i think i was like in
seventh
sixth or seventh grade
and we didn't win and we got a
participation trophy for baseball my mom
was like
don't bring that trophy home yeah
yeah winners win losers lose like and
that's what it is
but that's but you got to work hard to
understand what it's like to win yeah
and also you got to be willing to lose
to know what it's like to win exactly
bro you know what i mean if you don't if
you're not willing to lose
then like you can't take a l yeah bro
you can't take a [ __ ] l
get eat a dick okay eat a
eat a fat dick i will say that right now
if you are scared to take a [ __ ] l
in just anything in [ __ ] life then
damn you [ __ ]
you are a sour pants
and i said sour pants like i'm a [ __ ]
five-year-old bro all right or 85 year
old bullies molded us bro bullies molded
us yeah hard [ __ ] in high school i mean
the high school i don't know how your
high school was but the high school i
went to bro
if you ain't coming
you told us you said you said you people
would roast you all the time about being
a bigger dude and then what did you do
rose back and look where it's gotten you
right bro people will make fun of me all
the time
about the [ __ ] music i listen to
right
right and look look where i'm at right
chappelle's world [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but like like
dude
uh actually no one really made fun of me
about cheerleading but anyone that did
they probably did it silently because
they know i beat their ass
but
we had a male cheerleader when i was in
what was that middle school was he
better than me um i don't think so yeah
i ain't never seen you chair [ __ ]
i seen you flip you could flip yeah his
name was like alex i'm a world champ his
dark skinned dude too bro was he good
sure i don't know yeah yeah yeah you
can't you can't get a solid gauge of
yeah i don't know what's good i'm
sitting here trying to bully this man
that ain't even here right now i'm like
was he good dog i think this i don't
know what he's doing i only remember his
last name but was he gay um that was
what we used to say
yeah
that that was the question we used to
have really yeah
is he gay is he yeah is he and then i i
actually dated a um
what was that
what
freshman year
college like i dated a competitive
cheerleader oh you did yeah was she uh
this was in georgia also georgia
all-stars
wow
i had a lot of friends cheer there yeah
yeah
yeah it's so wild like i'll get people
that'll come up to me at the shows like
and you know they're hearing me talk
about cheerleading they're like yo did
you
um know uh
do you know this like cheer
team or whatever blah blah blah every
[ __ ] time never fails and i'm like
yeah i know that [ __ ] team i was like
that's my world man yeah well i don't
know when it starts but like when you
start georgia all-stars is a big one
yeah george all-stars is a big one and
the other one you guys got out there is
uh another one i don't know you probably
won't know it it's called stingray
all-stars i just knew that one because
she knew that one because she okay i
used to go to her competition i went to
like a couple of them uh
so this other thing i do david is
rapid fire questions
ready
favorite band
who didn't blow fish favorite rapper
kanye west
whoo
let's take this take a pause for a
second
kanye west
i
[ __ ] love
kanye west i tried to get a photo of up
here but every time i looked for a fly
it was just like
[ __ ] horrible it's my favorite bruh i
[ __ ] with him so heavy that's my dog all
the way that's my job everyone i mean i
don't listen i can go off about this i
everyone thinks he's [ __ ] crazy
but for some reason
i feel he's saying completely i feel
like he's sane
you're right there with me i feel like
he is
sane i don't know what it is about him
but i'm like
i don't know i don't think he's crazy
because i think the reason we see it is
because as comedians nobody really sees
your vision until it actually happens
and then
you're like i tried to tell you
[ __ ] 10 years ago yeah because
that that's exactly what i was going to
say i i've said this to people before
that are like question i go
and especially especially other
comedians i go you ever try to run a
joke by somebody or tell them that you
have this thought or or someone that's
something that you're trying to create
and they go i don't know what you're
talking about and then when you
then when you go forward with it and do
it and then you and then they see and
they're like oh [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
right that's one of the dopest things
ever that's how i that's what i feel
about kanye west yeah i can go off about
that dude's catalogue all [ __ ] day
man he he could be he could be anybody
in the verses
oh yeah 100 i think i mean anybody i
think i mean just
he's unstoppable i think the 808 album
can beat anybody
yeah ate away the heartbreak that's a
great one yeah bro i i said some i said
something to someone in
my beautiful dark twisted fantasy
musically oh what are you gonna what do
you
know you're gonna [ __ ] nobody ca i
don't i think that album can go against
anybody anybody it demolishes majority
people's house when they were when it
was the drake and kanye thing
uh i was team kanye all the way i mean
kanye did better than jake
i was think kanye i couldn't listen i
listened to the drake album and
and i'm a drake fan but it you know it
was similar to like it was like oh okay
like it was like his like he has like a
structure where he like he found his
like
way of like making like an album and
it's like okay it's a good album but
like kanye he'll throw something
different right at you every time
college dropout sounds completely
different than [ __ ] my beautiful dark
twisted fantasy you know what i mean
like his structure is just like you
never know what you're gonna get when he
drops an album yeah you know and that's
what i [ __ ] uh i think he's the most
influential person of our lifetime bruh
okay so here's another thing you ready
for this i said this and people think
i'm [ __ ] nuts
um
you know how like they they always have
like that comparison like like
of the music world like like the michael
jackson right like we'll never have
another one like that
i think connie's the closest comparison
i in my opinion i'd say he's
bigger than michael jackson
like on the whole
entertainer person wise i'd say yeah
because bro just
think about how crazy it sound to sell
adidas without stripes
i didn't even think about that but yeah
yeezys no stripes these are leader
stripes on it and they're adidas shoes
right
that is [ __ ] crazy yeah
you know because like yeah i don't know
if yeah michael didn't have the fashion
like that
you know what i mean he had like the
the worldwide you know fame and like
people would you know go crazy at his
concerts and stuff like that like
you know i've seen kanye you ever seen
kanye live yeah a few times [ __ ]
insane
insane and i saw him early on
i saw him when he came out with his
second album uh
um i saw the one yeah yeah it was the
touch to sky tour
what the [ __ ] that album late
registration late registration late
registration i saw i saw when he he was
only on his sophomore album and [ __ ]
still hands down one of the best
concerts i think i've ever been to and
that was 2005. yeah you know what i mean
like i i honestly like when you think of
like big musicians like that like
you know some people could like
i think have tried to like compare
beyonce closer to the the michael
jackson
realm
um
but i but for me it's it's kanye well
yeah kanye bro he
he
not only did he do it in rap and then he
went and made a gospel album that was
dope that's what i'm saying
and like for it to be like legit and
good yeah and on top of it on top of the
gospel album he was
running like these dope sunday services
you see what i'm saying like they're
like i went to a few of them you went to
some of the sunday services what were
those like
uh so the first one i went to
um
because my home girls were saying in the
choir shout out to ashley what's up
shout out to ashley yeah so girl the
first one we went to was like inside
this building like over here in like
burbank glendale area yeah yeah and uh
the second one i went to um
and then my boy also my boy also played
he's the bass player for the for the
sunday choir shout out to nick what's up
dog oh really yeah oh hell yeah
so the first one i went to was there and
then the second one i went to was at uh
the farm
okay yeah oh you were yeah you went to
that one or whatever yeah i remember
that was like one of but they were free
weren't they
all free or something like that
somewhere
you got yeah you got in because
but i think it was something like uh
you have to like pre-order his album and
okay with two tickets or something like
that yeah yeah something dude
man
i'm i'm a fan even even like his like
[ __ ] feature [ __ ] yeah
you know like the uh
um
one of my favorites is uh one of our
favorites
is the one he did with slum village oh
yeah i'm calling
baby i'm selfish
and don't be trying to come around my
girl acting like mr [ __ ]
it's not a spot
damn yeah all right i had to had to
pause that moment for uh
your favorite so okay okay i guess
the we might know the sans favorite
concert
yay
yeah
yeah yeah absolutely
it's between
yeah yay bro because
the visuals along with the concert it's
an experience [ __ ] experience not
even just a concert and that's what and
that's why i said i i i would give him
more of a comparison to michael jackson
than than anybody else because because
of what he he puts out there at his
concert like you really feel it like you
see like i've been i've been to so many
[ __ ] concerts that i can't even
remember but when you um
and i've seen a lot of people do a lot
of visual stuff blah blah
you know but like
everyone does it but to make people like
feel something
on top of it
is different you know and like he makes
you feel something on top of it as well
like you like like i don't know like
it's like you're like pulled into his
right to this to his world yeah it's
between kanye and erica baidu best
concert okay
yeah you got some solid ones yeah okay
um
favorite album
that's so hard
um the jesus happened
to use this album
damn that's a great one yeah on site
yeah on site
blood on the leaves bounce down
bounce
i know
you're tired of loving
it with nobody
christian didn't believe me he was like
david could sing
what did you say
why would i lie about that
of all things i could lie about why
would i lie about david knowing how to
sing actually i've lied about some of
the stupidest [ __ ] all right honey yeah
uh okay now we do this thing which is
like a soundtrack to the episode it's
the playlist it'll be the david lucas
play with his playlist so we go back and
forth and pick songs for the playlist we
do like 10 to 12 songs let's do it um
i'll go first i'll do
i'll do kanye west's uh i wonder
and then followed by kodak black peachy
okay
you know you need it why would you call
that black will you write code that
black sorry picking calamari on my teeth
uh
i'll do
if we're gonna go over in that world
i'll do the uh
so i see boys oh
yeah what was that song uh
[ __ ] what is that song i'm gonna tell
you right now
you'll find it out let go let's type in
uh so i see boys
uh no it's it's about yeah it's the
the song is i think i think it's called
so i see boys too oh yeah so i see boys
two
it's called yeah
this that's what this yep yeah yep big
scar big scar yes so big scar so icy
boys two
is the
i'll go with that one rum gold
rum dash gold a dot gold excuse me
get through
i'll do slum village uh selfish since we
were just singing it um
was that good
well oh [ __ ] it i just sang let's see uh
eric about dude times are wasting i just
put baidu times away
b.a.d.u
you're right you're right you're right
you're right um
i'll do if we're going to go that route
i'll do uh
common
we'll do the light
there is a light so let's do it uh
brooks and don
[Music]
yeah we got to switch it up on him a
little bit uh if we're going to go that
route then i'll do
oh i'll do you know i did i did this one
last week but or did one by him last
week but i'll do another one i'll do
that charlie crockett song you showed me
the seven
um
was it seven minutes
seven sorry seven come eleven
seven eleven
booty collins i'd rather be with you i'd
rather be with you boo
yeah
that was good i'd rather be with you
until that day we'll fly away
uh i'll do gap band
outstanding
how many we got casey
11.
all right you want to close it out let's
see what you got
uh
rod wave close enough to hurt
did i know that one
by rod wade
rod rod rod
wave yeah
you might not know that
yeah
so this will be the playlist i posted in
the description at the end of every
episode also if you follow the chapel's
world instagram page i do
post it in there
um
uh in the uh we have like a highlights
right christian yes sir yeah so we have
a highlights uh on the instagram page
sorry i'm a boomer which is what they
tell me every day
and uh
you can see those playlists as well and
you
there's a link to the playlist in those
descriptions or whatever so yeah but
david lucas where are you at
uh where yeah what you got any days
bro punchline squad so this so thursday
because this comes out thursday at 3 p.m
we'll be in atlanta with brendan schaub
at the punchline plus line uh punchline
comedy club yeah or whatever five shows
thursday through uh saturday will be out
there any individual stuff you got
coming over just that right now right
now not right now okay
and then uh i'll do mine real quick
casey but just go to uh david lucas yeah
davidlucas.com davidlucascomedy.com
davidlucascomedy.com
sold out of a lot of the shirts thank
all of y'all who support it uh we'll be
reading up soon so y'all can go grab
y'all shirts okay sold out of his merch
also uh check out david's podcast it's
also part of the thick boy
um
network as well
uh
drops every friday drops every friday
it's david going back and forth with
random people roasting so how do
people that want to get on and try to
roast you back how do they get on
message the uh thick boy instagram and
then they'll send you the link okay so
message the dickboy instagram they'll
send you the link and then you could see
if you got the [ __ ] chops to hang
with
david ruthless [ __ ] lucas you
know what i'm saying
uh david thank you for [ __ ] coming
through of course though uh i enjoy
being on the [ __ ] road with you man
yeah man it's gonna it's gonna be it's
gonna be dope when we're able to do our
own thing and headline our own also a
bummer because we won't be on the road
like you know what i'm saying like when
we headline it's gonna be dope because
you know we're making the headline of
money but yeah the fun the fun yeah it's
different when i'm about you know when
you're out by yourself it's just like
it's so boring damn really
where the hell he's at until until you
can build your team you know yeah so you
can build your team but all right thanks
for coming through of course appreciate
it
you